لا جديد يذكر مواجهه جديده بين ليفربول
وريال مدريد في دوري ابطال اوروبا
والنتيجه واحده الفريق الاسباني يقسوا على
الراس في ذهاب دوري السته عشر هذه المره
في عقر داره وبين جماهيره في التفاصيل نجح
حامل اللقب مدريد في تحويل تاخره بهدفين
امام ليفربول خلال اول ربع ساعه من
المباراه الى فوز عريض بنتيجه مان الى
خمسه قبل نحو 25 دقيقه من النهايه مباراه
مثيره شهدت خطاين فادحين لافضل حارسي مرمى
في العالم الاولى من تيبو كورت وحارس
مدريد الذي اهدى هدفا لصلاح لكن الرد اتى
من اليسون بكر حارس ليفربول الذي قدم هديه
مماثله قبل صافره الشوط الاول بهذا الفوز
وضع ريال مدريد قدما في الدوري ربع
النهائي من البطوله لكنه ايضا مغص فرحه
محمد صلاح برقم القياس الجديد فبعد هدفه
امس اصبح الهداف التاريخي لليفربول في
ابطال اوروبا برصيد 42 هدفا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]